Website, running it out, lead generation.
Oh, there we go.
Recording started lead generation, building a website and ranking it is the
exact same skillset as having an SEO client who you build a website for and
do the SEO you don't own the website.
The client does, but in my mind, I wanted to make, you know, I wanted to make
lead gen work, but then I saw opportunities coming my way for easy wins.
And, you know, business owners, I knew connections I had, Hey, can you do my
website for me now that they knew I had that skillset and I was like, man, I
would way rather work for you than work for my job, right?
So I'm like, okay, I can do that.
And we structure a deal.
Okay.
500 bucks a month.
I'll build you a new website and I won't charge you for the new website
build, even though it's a website development.
Like I can do it so well with employees worldwide, so cheap.
I can build a website for $40 is my cost.
I'll do that for free and you just pay me 500 bucks a month and you'll get the
website, you'll get the SEO work, you'll get everything.
And now I have these cash reserves.
And so once that clicked for me, I was like, wow, I just need to take those
easy wins and yeah, lead gen is awesome.
Keep building that, keep building those sites, keep ranking those things.
But I want to get out of my job ASAP.
And that's what clicked for me.
And I was like, okay, if I can do it once, you know, I bought this program,
um, your program and another program to learn.
And it took me like four months and I was grinding, grinding, making no money
until that first deal kind of came my way.
And I was like, okay, I have the skillset.
I'm going to do it.
And I took that first one.
And then I was like, wow, if I can just once the sites built and they're on,
it's just like mailbox money, 500 bucks a month, 500 bucks a month.
Um, and my team would just handle it.
And it was easy.
So I was like, man, if I can just stack those and get a hundred of those, get
150, get 200, that'll be life changing.
And that's exactly what happened.
So that's been the big breakthrough.
Like I think the main concept is like going from zero to one.
That's where people that are at jobs struggle with is getting the first client.
And so in my mind, I want to make getting the first client as easy as possible,
because once you have that first client, then the flood gets open because now the
pressure is on to deliver, to learn.
You'll learn way faster, get two, three, four, five, and your business will grow.
But you just got to go from zero to one.
So many people get stuck at that zero stage.
If you can get one, then you're rolling.
You're going.
So,
so the, the, the thing that is that Zach's kind of alluding to is that.
He was smart and he started targeting people.
And we're going to get into that a little bit, but he started targeting people who
already were paying for SEO services.
He wasn't going in.
My problem was I was trying to sell everyone SEO.
I was trying to sell the water bottle company, the restaurant, you know,
cause everyone technically could benefit from SEO, right?
Every single company, the Kleenex brand, everyone can benefit from SEO.
And I was trying to go and sell people on SEO and on why they should use me.
And Zach realized there's a subset of the market out there that are already paying
300, 500, $700 a month, and all he's got to do is switch them over to his service.
Give them a much pre, a much more premium service for the same price, or
even a little bit less, and dude, these people are set it and forget it.
These people are going to be paying this bill forever.
So, uh, Zach, how does somebody go from the zero to one?
Like, let's just use an example, um, Killpot 5000.
I'm not sure what your real name is, but let's just say Killpot's sitting in a
nine to five job and is tired of freaking trading their time for dollars,
waking up, punching the clock, barely making it work, not able to go to the
gym because they're tired, coming back depressed, no money, no, nothing's
exciting about their situation and they want to go and they want to make that
first deal.
How does somebody go from zero to one if they want to start today?
Awesome question.
When I started, I thought, what is the lowest hanging fruit?
What is the easiest sale?
And it's through your network.
So any business owner that you know, you just, you don't want to go in pitching,
but you want to just go and ask him questions.
You want to learn, you want to ask him questions.
Hey, how's your business doing?
How are you guys doing online?
How do you like your website?
How are you guys ranking?
What would you like to do better online?
And you just start the discussion and they'll just be honest with you
because they trust you.
So you have your network, but then a step further is anybody, you know,
that knows a business owner.
So then once I talked to someone, I'd be like, awesome.
Yeah.
Do you know any other business owners I could talk to that might be
wanting to grow their business?
And of course, tons and tons of business owners want to grow their business.
So if you just work your network, you can usually get anywhere from
three to 10 deals right there.
And those initial deals are really important because it'll build your
confidence and you can go from there.
Once you've kind of worked your immediate network, their network, then
it's like just people around you in your, in your city, in your neighborhood,
business owners that where it's easy, like, Hey, yeah, I live right down the street.
You know, I'm in, I live in queen Creek, Arizona.
I'm like, yeah, I'm right here in queen Creek.
Um, I'd love to just, you know, kind of talk to you about your
business a little bit, like, how are you guys doing?
And since you have a tie to them, you have a connection.
It's an easy conversation starter.
Um, especially when you're new, people get nervous, but essentially if you're
able to get someone to open up and you ask these questions I'm talking about,
they open up and then you just say, Oh, cool.
You want to do this thing.
I actually have the skills to do that thing.
How much are you currently paying for your current thing that you're getting
now for your website, for your SEO?
Oh, 300 bucks a month.
Awesome.
I'll do it for that same price and I'll give you way better service.
And I'm here local and you know, list goes on and on and I'm a small business
instead of that big company that you're with.
So those are some initial thoughts for dual from zero to one network, their
network, people in your neighborhood, and then just calling businesses.
Like you got to put in the reps.
So if you have zero clients and you're trying to get the first one, talk with
five business owners every day.
And that consistency will get you one client, two clients, you'll get better
at it, three clients, four clients, and it'll start building and that momentum
will just carry you forward.
So that's kind of what I'd say to go from zero to one.
So that's what I did.
Did you just make a list of all like being pretty practical here on steps?
Did you just sit there and go, okay, here's all the people that I know that
are owned businesses and then let me send them a message.
Let me call them.
Like, what was that?
What would that look like?
Was it just like, here's every single person that owns a business in
general or these types of businesses?
Or how did you, did you just compile a list?
Great question.
I literally pulled up a Google sheet with my free Gmail, pulled up a Google
sheet and I wanted business owners that were like service businesses, which I
don't really know many other business owners that aren't like providing a
service, maybe there's like an e-commerce business, I wouldn't focus on that.
Maybe there's manufacturing, wouldn't do that.
But most business owners that, you know, in your neighborhood are going to be
small business owners and that those are great people to talk to.
So I just pulled up a Google sheet and I just started writing names,
just brainstorming.
Once I ran out of names, I pulled up my phone and I just started slowly going
through the hundreds of contacts in my phone and adding somebody, adding
somebody, adding somebody.
And that was my simple first, like CRM to track what was going on with everybody.
Right.
So the first column was everybody's name.
And then I went through my Facebook friends and I went through the
whatever and got my list and maybe I have 20 to 30 people and I'm, it
doesn't sound like many, but you start talking to them and you start realizing
there's all these needs, all these unmet needs and people are generally
unsatisfied with who they've worked with.
Generally big marketing companies don't do a good job and don't care enough
about each individual client.
And so people are usually upset when they see a client that they don't
usually upset, which makes an easy, easy sale to slide in and help them out.
Or people don't understand things.
So if you just have the knowledge and just teach people, um, they will kind
of come to you as the expert, Hey, yeah, even if you don't work with me, I
would recommend doing this, this, and this, um, you can do it on your own.
I can help you do it and you can pay me to do it for you.
Like, and that's the conversation that's get started.
So I think like simple scales, the more simple you can make it, especially in
the beginning, the more you're going to scale if you overcomplicate it and you
start worrying about like, Oh shoot, how am I going to do, um, blog posts and
back linking and all this complicated stuff is like, who cares?
You don't have a client.
Just make a very simple list.
Start talking to those people.
If you don't know the answers, pull up chat GPT and type in, Hey, what do I do
here?
And you can tell the person, Hey, yeah, that's a great question.
I've actually haven't come across.
So before, let me look it up real quick, figure it out.
And you're like, okay.
And live while you're talking to them, you're solving their problems and
showing that you want to work with them.
So I think just keep it really simple, build the list, use free works
resources like Google sheets.
And now, you know, you have the names, then you have your notes in the next
column, this date, talk to them, make sure to call them again on Friday.
Right.
It's so basic, but that's why it's effective because you actually use it.
So that's how I got started.
Did you find that a lot of the people that you were reaching out to on your
list were already paying for a similar type of service?
They were paying somebody to host their website or were you basically, you
know, having to, to get them to pay you something they weren't already paying?
Awesome question.
Um, almost everyone was paying for their website and is it's pretty rare for a
business owner and an electrician, a plumber, a carpet cleaner to build their
own website, it just takes too much time.
Like they don't, they're focused on making money, doing plumbing, doing
carpet, me doing whatever their thing is.
And they don't think about it.
When I, I, it always comes back to me to, in college, when I did sales, I
sold door to door selling direct TV.
And it was so hard.
It was a gnarly experience.
Like I was in Houston in the summer.
It's like 105 degrees and humid.
I'm just sweating like crazy.
But in a hundred days, it was like a three month summer.
I made $70,000 as a college kid.
And I don't watch TV.
Like I don't care about TV.
It's it's I've never really cared about TV.
And so you're like, man, how, how was that even possible?
I didn't believe in the TV.
What I believed in was saving people money.
And I could save people money by switching them from dish network or
AT&T, you verse to direct TV.
And that switch was so easy.
If they were paying $150 a month, I could get them all the same channels
plus NFL Sunday ticket for $70 a month.
So less than half the price.
And they get every single football game the next fall and they get all the
channels, right?
So that switch was so easy.
And that summer in a hundred days, I did 300 switches and made $70,000.
So when I was learning Legion and learning websites and learning SEO, it
kind of clicked all of a sudden.
And I was like, Whoa, how could I get people that are already paying for
this to just switch to me and I can give them more channels and NFL Sunday
ticket, right?
I was like, okay, I'm just going to find the people that are paying 300, 500,
700 bucks a month, a thousand, whatever they're paying and match their
bit and over deliver on the services.
So, okay, you're paying $500 a month for your website and SEO.
I'll do 500 bucks a month for your website and SEO.
And I'll also help you with a Google review strategy and make you a custom
link you can use, and you can call me anytime I'm way more accessible.
And we actually write high quality content, you know, like all these things.
They're like, Oh yeah, that's a no brainer.
And when you're starting out, it's a no brainer for them.
It's, it's no additional money.
But for you, you just went from zero to making 500 bucks a month with one
client, and that is a huge game changer.
That's what I love seeing and love helping people do is like go from that
zero to 500 to a thousand to 10,000.
And when you hit 10,000 months, recurring revenue, most people are
basically free to quit their job and just scale.
And it's so fun to, to a lot to happen and help people do that.
So,
so for those that just jumped on, for those that aren't following, basically
the strategy from a high level is using SEO, which is taking people's websites,
ranking them on Google, you are going to go to your contact list, the people
that you know, your warm network, especially, and specifically the home
service businesses, you're going to go in with a wit, like it, with the mindset
of I'm going to add value, I'm going to help, I'm going to see how I can add
value and sure, if they want to pay me great, if not, I'm still going to be
that person that's like adding value.
You go in most likely, you're going to be able to offer them the exact same
thing, plus one or two additional things, more value for the same price or less.
And doing that strategy, you're going to be able to stack your first one, two,
three, four, five, 10 clients.
That's from a, from like, uh, that's a very simple, simplified way to say it,
but that's essentially what strategy is.
Right.
Yeah.
And then you just, um, always are improving that.
So once you have a couple of clients and you're like, Whoa, these switches are
easy, you start hearing more names of like, Oh, wow, this big marketing
company does a terrible job.
These people do a bad job.
This software is expensive and I can, you know, pull clients or cross sell.
You know, they could have that software and use me for their site.
Um, and you start, you know, getting lists and like attacking easy went.
And that's how I just really start snowballing is you're like, wow, I can
just hone in on exactly who I want to target for some people it's, it's
niches like, Ooh, I'm, I'm really good with carpet cleaners because my dad owns
a carpet cleaning company, I'm going to focus on carpet cleaners.
I can speak their language or other people, you know, find a company.
This big marketing company is terrible.
No one likes them.
They have terrible reviews.
I'm just going to pull people over.
Um, and so figuring out those strategies has been huge.
Yeah.
So the, the initial few clients is just hitting your network.
And then from there, you've got to have a bigger strategy.
That's something that you can, you could turn into a system.
And that's what Zach, the reason that Zach's been able to get to $56,000 per
month is not because he's got a network with that many people, but his initial
clients in that, I think you're right, dude, it's the same thing with digital
real estate, right?
Going from zero to one gives you all the confidence in the world to, Oh my
gosh, this is actually going to work.
And then the second deal becomes easier.
And the third deal and the fourth deal and the fifth deal.
And so guys, the reason why.
I didn't do SEO correctly is first and foremost, I was targeting big juicy
retainers because that's what I like to do with digital real estate.
I like to get thousand 1500.
I had a client, an SEO client.
It was paying me $4,000 per month.
And honestly, that was the same client that caused me to stop doing SEO.
Because while I was on vacation, that same individual called me and canceled
and it like completely just ruined my vacation because it took like 40% of
my 40 or probably like 50% of my revenue at that point.
And what Zach does is he goes in strategically and goes to people that
are already comfortable paying a small micro bill and they have been, and
he's just switching them over.
Instead of selling someone on this new concept, he's taking people that are
already paying in general and just funneling that money into himself.
Yeah.
He does a little bit of work upfront.
And then after that, a lot of it set it and forget it.
The second thing that he did really well, it's genius.
And if you guys are like, man, this might distract me guys.
If you do what Zach's doing, which is targeting home service businesses, you
can literally go target your future digital real estate clients.
Like you could go in and say, Hey, I'm only going to target clients in tree
service or concrete or spray foam insulation, and I'm going to go get their
SEO, get in the door with their SEO at 500 bucks a month.
And guess what?
The only reason they want SEO is because they want leads.
So now I got their trust.
Now I'm going to take some of that money.
I'm going to go set up a strategy using what Nick talks about, put up a landing
page to put an ad up, run some ads, get them additional leads and say, Hey, Mr.
business owner, what do you think about buying these leads from my project as
well?
And now all of a sudden you have people that already trust you and it's the
easiest sell in the world to go for that second, third, fourth money.
So I wish I had done this.
I was an idiot.
I was literally taking, I had a.
A client that had a restaurant, a Mexican restaurant.
I had a client that did like wedding performances, like wedding bands, like
they would go and do like the, they like that type of a thing.
Great clients by the way, but they just, I was so spread out, dude.
And then I had like this foundation repair client that I had, uh, what else
did I even have at the time?
I had so many different things.
I didn't know how to speak the language and guys, all these people did not have
SEO, so I was a bill, right?
Zach's going in and he's like, look, you already have a bill.
Let me just, you just pay it to me instead.
I'm going to give you a way superior service.
And by the way, Zach, it's funny because I did door to door.
I sold home security systems, not direct TV, but I had the exact same strategy
is I realized really early on, dude, just go target the people that are already
paying the whoever sold them the security the first time they did the hard work.
They convinced them that they needed the bill.
Now I just got to show them that my product, my offering is a better
offering than theirs, simple, easy sale, no emotion, 20 minutes in and out.
Boom, boom, boom.
And I just made my commission.
So, um, the beautiful thing about SEO, the beautiful thing about lead gen is
that it's recurring, right?
You get paid again and again and again.
And Zach, I don't even think you've even gone and cashed in yet and went and
sold the, the lead gen on the backend.
But when you do, I think you're going to increase your revenue 10 to $20,000
overnight, because you probably are sitting on, uh, I don't know how many
clients and projects that you could go and sell, but I know you have such a
good system right now.
You're like, let me just keep, keep adding these on, but, um, let's talk
about your business really quick.
How many, how many clients is your $56,000 made up of?
Um, we have like 170 clients.
So your average clients between like, what, about three to 400 bucks?
Three, three to 400 bucks.
And a lot of them honestly, um, just stay forever.
So if you look at like the lifetime value of a client, it's like over
five, six, 7,000, because they just stay and pay that for so long.
And like the clients that we lose over time, some people like will retire or
like things like that or some, you know, it's like, it's like, Oh, are you
going to like give your company to your son?
One guy is actually, Hey, I'm retiring.
And he's like, Oh, actually I'm going to give my business to my son.
But now we still have him as a client.
And he was just like, goes and goes and goes.
And so over time, it's pretty crazy to see how like an easy sale and a system
where it's just like, my team just takes care of these people and does their stuff.
Very easy to set up that team.
And now I never think about it.
I never have a call.
They don't have my phone number.
They, they can email our support line or email my support team.
And I don't even know when we lose clients anymore or get them.
It's like, it's just so fractional small that we just keep adding them.
And then here and there, someone retires, whatever happens.
Right.
But there's not the stress.
There's the complete freedom of like the systems are going really well.
And now I just think about the big picture stuff.
How can I hire someone really cool to do this thing?
How can I think of a new strategy for sales?
And then my sales team does it.
So it's been very, very fun to grow it and then just plug people in that are
phenomenal at building websites, phenomenal at whatever they do and, and
just watch it compound over time since people are so sticky and stay so long.
It's really cool.
Yeah, that's dope, dude.
And you know what?
I used to hate the idea of having a ton of clients like that, but what I love
about having 150 clients is you have a business that's built brick by brick by
brick that you literally placed each one and it took a while to build, but it's
not going to crumble overnight, right?
You don't have one huge client that's like literally got you by the fricking
throat that's saying like, Hey, you better give me a better price or I'm going to
quit, dude, you could lose five clients tomorrow and you really wouldn't actually
feel it.
You know what I'm saying?
So that's, I like that strategy a lot.
The other reason I like it is because again, dude, when you decide to monetize
on the backend and you go and sell them lead generation, dude, if you can get 10%
of those people at a thousand dollars a month, you know, 15% of those people,
you're just increasing five, $10,000 per month right there.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
And the thing is like, I already know which people are perfect because there's
trust there and they come to us and say, Hey, we want more leads.
We want to run ads or do whatever.
It's like, that's an inbound lead to sell.
So you're perfectly positioned to do that.
For sure.
So tell everyone real quick, because dude, one thing that I realized when I started
doing this, you know, my, my dream was like, dude, I want to become a millionaire
by, you know, 30 years old.
I think that's such a cliche answer.
Everybody has, but that was me.
I've been writing that down in my little journal since I was 18.
And, and then when I hit it, it was like, okay, let's go bigger.
Let's go bigger.
And I've always like, I, then it's like, I want to be, I want to get
a million dollars a month.
Like that's, you know, the goal.
And I thought like, and I was always speaking to this and dude, it was literally
like a couple of weeks ago, I did a poll and I did it on here.
I did it in the Facebook group.
I did it to my digital landlords community.
And I just asked everyone like, what do you guys want?
And I put some options and it was like, uh, security, respect, um, whatever.
And then somebody, I didn't even put this and somebody added freedom.
And dude, everybody wanted that answer.
And so I started like thinking about it and I was like, you know what?
I think that like all that people want is they want to be able to make enough
money to be free from their freaking job and from what they're doing right now
and to go and do what they like to do.
And so Zach, I want you to tell everyone, like what, when you started, tell
everyone what, how your life was.
The job that you had, what your schedule was like.
And then I want you to tell everyone, like, and I know you're very humble, so
you would never say much, but like, tell everyone, like some of the cool stuff
you've done over the past in 2024, cause you're getting as bad as me, dude.
Every time I call you or text you, you're in some other country surfing
or something like that.
So, but yeah, tell it really, we're kind of going backwards, but tell everyone
your story as far as like where you were a couple of years ago, when you were
still in the J O B and then tell everyone like what this year's looked like for you.
Yeah, that is pretty interesting to think about that contrast and go back and
enter that space of like December, 2021.
Um, I still had a job.
It was a sales job and, um, our manager, new manager was like, okay, you got to
make a hundred cold calls a day because we don't have enough leads coming in.
When I was just used to like closing deals and I was like, Whoa, wait a
second, that's crazy.
And I had a conversation with my wife.
I was like, I really, really don't want to do this.
If I'm going to call a hundred people a day to sell this software that the
software company I was working for, if I'm going to do that, why don't I just
call a hundred people a day for my own company?
And I quickly was like, get me out of here.
Like I'm hustling so hard building someone else's dream.
It was a cool software, but I'm not, I don't truly care about it.
Right.
What I care about is helping small business owners like my dad that are
target cleaners and small businesses succeed.
So that was my mindset.
And I was like, I have to get out of here ASAP.
So, um, you know, it was like, it was like the handcuffs, like you had to, like,
there was like check-in meeting 8 AM, check out 5 PM.
Like it was remote.
I was in my house, but it was like, it was like handcuffs.
You had to like be on and your calls were being tracked.
And I was just like, Whoa, this is the new manager came in and it was
intense tons of calls to make every day.
And then like, you know, everyone in the company ranked and just,
just pretty intense stuff.
And I was like, it was just heavy.
And so then once I committed, I was like, my wife supported me and we're like,
okay, I'll just like grind and hustle and build my own thing.
What I did more and more over time is just essentially buying back my time.
You know, most people, when you're working for income, you're
trading your time for money.
Um, once I owned my own company, I was making more money.
I could trade my money for time.
I could employ people.
I could pay somebody and now they take care of all that work.
And I would buy myself back my time.
And so I just kept doing that month after month after month to now this year.
Um, I mean, last year, beginning of 2023, I was still closing deals.
Um, and then I was like, okay, I've hit a point.
I no longer need to close deals for my company.
And I hired a salesperson.
I hired a customer support, hired an SEO team, hired, um, SDRs like.
I hired everybody website builders and you know, it was, it was step by step.
And then the last couple of key hires were like a salesman
to completely take over sales and the sales team.
And now that I have a sales team in place, all the systems in place,
all the fulfillment in place, essentially, um, my day to day is.
I could honestly do whatever I want whenever I want.
I enjoy working and adding value.
So like I still work and I, I love training my team, helping them up skill.
I love hiring new people, um, going after new ideas and basically just
leading the team to crush it.
And that's what I'm all about.
Now is just helping people grow, helping other businesses grow.
Um, but yeah, like this year I went, it was kind of the last second thing.
Some buddies were going to Nicaragua on a surf trip and they were like, um,
they had their crew set, then someone dropped out and they're like, man,
who could go last second?
They called me and I'm like, yeah, I'm in.
So then I just can all of a sudden pick up and go to Nicaragua.
And it was epic.
Like we just were in Nicaragua on the beach would swim out with our surfboards
to a boat and the boat would drop drive up and down the coastline to the different
surf spots.
And we would just surf these different breaks that were incredible along the
cliffs in Nicaragua.
So that was, that was a fun trip.
We went to Hawaii for like over a month and got an Airbnb on the beach.
So our kids every day, we just wake up and walk out to the sand for a month.
Like that was pretty life changing.
Um, but I still feel like I was adding value because I was on the beach in
Hawaii or I was in the house and I was reading good books, you know,
and my kids is taking a nap.
I'm reading a good book.
And then I'm like, whoa, I'm just the idea guy now.
So I get this idea and boom, I just train, train the team, teach the team and
they, they take care of it.
So the super fun spot to be, um, when you say freedom, that's what everybody wants.
That's what I feel like this business model allows.
Yes, you need to grind.
You need to like hustle and get the first client, get that confidence, help those
stack, but there is a huge piece of mind knowing you have over a hundred clients,
plenty of money, plenty of savings, a team that's totally capable that you've
trained and now you can kind of do what you want with your day to day.
And one of the things that lights me up, like I have new goals now, like my
lifetime vision, my 25 year goal is to help thousands of business owners grow
their businesses and grow as people.
So that's what I'm all about is just helping other businesses grow,
helping other people grow.
And so I love studying self-improvement business growth.
And that's what I do now is just basically coach my team and then coach other
business owners on how to grow fast.
And it's so fulfilling.
I love it.
So that's kind of been a long answer to what this year's looked like for me,
but it's been an amazing year.
And when you were doing the job, you were making, I think I remember it was
like, what was it after taxes?
What was your take home?
I would take home each month 4,600.
I had like a 70,000 a year salary, but after taxes, you have 4,600 a month.
$4,600 a month, dude.
Um, can you imagine like now that you've experienced making $56,000 a month,
dude, I do not know, and this is all due respect, but like, I don't know how
people can live on less than like 15.
Like, obviously I do.
You cut the stupid stuff, but like when you're used to like not checking prices
at the grocery store or on the menu and stuff, like it's, it's, it's mind blog.
I don't know how at 4,600 bucks a month in 2024, how in the world people with it,
with kids, with a spouse, dude, I couldn't even live on that single, bro.
You know what I mean?
Like it's, it's, it's bananas, dude.
So, um, it's crazy.
What I'm getting at is it's crazy that you're just at your six months away,
six months away at any time from like completely buying your freedom or
completely getting your freedom.
And dude, there is nothing better than like, I always say this.
It's like when your mom asks you to clean your room, it sucks.
It sucked when you're a kid, right?
My mom doesn't ask me to clean my room anymore.
Thank goodness.
I have, I, I, I do that myself or I pay somebody to do that.
But when you, as a kid would go and like, Hey, I'm going to surprise my mom
and just clean my room on my own, dude.
It was amazing, right?
You've got the, the energy.
It's just like work.
Like even though you and I don't have to work, I still wake up, dude, it's
seven AM in Dubai, like I should probably be on a boat, you know?
Uh, but I, I, I'm choosing to work and I don't have to work, but I enjoy it.
And I like to build and I like to see that.
But so when you're doing it because you want to, it's so much more fulfilling.
You have energy to do it.
So I know it's just like, when you're in a job and you have to go, dude,
it freaking sucks, it freaking sucks.
Um, like for example, uh, uh, Jersey shore devil, he actually just joined
our digital landlords program.
We were talking about this.
He's, he does furniture sales and he's like, he makes really good money, but
he has to travel to different locations and he has to go and he'd be, he said
he would be in like Columbia and he would have to come and do it.
And like, so we talked about this exact same thing.
So, um, anyway, dude, it's, uh, the, the exciting part is for anyone listening
right now, you are, I would say if you would put your head down, turn off the
distractions, quit, get in quick, like chase and all this different stuff,
pick one thing and do it for a solid six months, six months.
I think that anyone in this stream could become free.
Some people sooner, some people it's going to take them longer to learn.
But I think six months is not unrealistic to think that by June, by
mid summer of next year, not even by June, by May, by April, end of April,
by freaking April fool's day, you could, you could completely have a different
life or you don't have to answer to a boss.
And then like there's a clear path that we're giving you guys.
So anyway, um, dude, killer killer, uh, training today, bro.
Hopefully this inspires some people, hopefully gives us some ideas.
Again, guys, the business model of digital real estate is building
sites, ranking them on Google with SEO.
And then renting out the leads.
So what Zach's doing is he picked one part of the process.
He's just focusing on the SEO.
He got really good at it and he's getting, he's stacking clients,
he's stacking clients, he's stacking clients.
So, um, if you are somebody like in a job, you're like, let me get out
as soon as I possibly can, you're in a situation like Zach was, or I was in
whatever, um, what we're going to do, Zach, I will put the link once this
video goes live, I think I can go and edit the description.
Um, let me see if I still have, actually, you know what I can do.
I'm going to put your website.
What is your website?
Zach Kyle.co Z A C K P O W E L L dot C O.
One thing I'll add on that thought too, is like, um, I had to kind of figure
this all out on my own and it was the slow way it was the grind.
Oh yeah.
Now people that I teach and coach up, it's just like, dude, here
is the exact way to do it.
And it's insane.
I even thought when I started helping people, Oh, this might take a year for them,
but people have done it in three or four months.
So the six months is like totally reasonable to go from zero to 10,000
months recurring revenue.
People have done it in four months.
Like six months, many multiple people have done it in six months.
It's totally possible.
Where, like you're saying by April, like the, they say focus is follow
one course until successful.
If you just focus and do this for six months, your life is completely different.
You go and you have, you now have that freedom to do what lights you up.
Do whatever you're passionate about.
Like it's amazing.
So I would just encourage you, if you're on the fence, like just go from zero to
one, you go from zero to one, that's the biggest sale of your life.
Go from zero to one, and then it'll just start snowballing and you'll look back
in April at today and be like, Whoa, Zach and Nick were telling me, and it's been
six months and I've earned my freedom.
It's like Braveheart, man.
Everyone wants freedom.
We don't actually realize like jobs aren't freedom.
When you're an entrepreneur at heart, like you want that freedom, just go out
and get it and commit.
And it's just that daily consistency that your daily standard right now, your
daily standards here, what you need to do is raise it and maybe your daily standard
now becomes talking with 10 business owners every day.
That's your new standard.
You have to abide by it in six months.
You've committed to that new standard.
You'll see the results of that higher standard you committed to.
So it's totally possible.
I just hope everyone will do it.
It's, it's amazing.
Yeah.
And, uh, I should add this, um, when I started digital landlords and, and, you
know, all my free, my free pro my, sorry, my free group and everything.
I'm I've been very, very cautious to not let people just come into my groups and
start like trying to sell stuff or, you know, check this out because everyone's
full of crap.
You know what I mean?
Like I see this happened inside of our free Facebook group, which by the way,
you guys, we, we have a free Facebook group at, uh, art of Dre art of D re.com.
Anyway, if I see somebody trying to sell something, dude, I kick them out.
I don't even give them a warning.
Um, because I hate that.
Like they're just getting there like little snakes in the grass.
Um, and so it's, there are very few people that I let onto my lives.
Uh, there are very few people that I let, uh, become like an admin of my group.
There's like a, the list is like two, um, because I want to make sure they actually
know what they're talking about and they're actually making money doing what
they're saying they're doing.
And so Zach is one of those people.
I would never just let somebody come on my life.
And this is like the fourth or fifth time we've talked.
Um, so obviously people know that I've, I've seen your stuff.
I know that your numbers are real.
You're not a, you're not a snake in the grass.
So anyway, what I would encourage you guys to do, if you just hopped on, go and
watch this.
As soon as we hop off, this thing will post to my, the community section on
YouTube and, uh, you guys go watch this from the beginning and go check out Zach's
website, zachpal.co we've had quite a few people, um, inside of who's misunderstood.
It says, hi, misunderstood.
Uh, you missed us, but this is going to be live here in just a second.
Um, go check it out.
Go check out Zach's site.
He, I've seen him take, and I've, I've talked to these people personally.
I've seen him take a handful of people to 10, 20.
There's one of the people that you train.
That's like, like, like at your heels, like almost to pass you.
Right.
Yeah.
52,000 monthly career revenue.
He's like, I'm going to catch you.
I'm like sick, dude.
It's like, there's the Jedi, the apprentice and boom, you're going to,
bro, it's like, uh, inside of digital lines, we have Ryan Dalton.
He's at like 87,000 a month.
And I'm like, dude, this dude's coming at for me, but it's the best.
It's like the best compliment in the world that somebody that you train
passes you, but, uh, it still gives you a little fire.
Like, dude, no, no, no, I want to be at the top guy, you know?
So, but, um, so yeah, guys, I'm going to link up Zach stuff.
Um, I'll get his socials and everything.
But yeah, check out his website, Zach pal.co.
He started just like you guys had a JLB wanted to have freedom.
And, uh, he's basically living the, the Tim Ferris life, going to
Nicaragua, going to Hawaii.
Yeah.
They just built him and his wife.
He wouldn't tell you guys this, but he just built a new house.
Um, all this is since we met and since he started doing this.
Cause I think when we met, dude, you were making like six, I think you
had started the business, but you were making like sub 10 K and now you're,
it's like your entire life has changed, dude.
It's crazy thinking how much your life could change in a
couple of years, you know?
Yeah.
It's mind boggling looking at that timeline.
Um, a lot can change quick, man.
If you just commit daily consistency, you guys will get there.
So let me ask you one more question.
This is the last thing I'm going to ask you.
How did you get, what did, did your wife believe in what you were
doing when you first started?
And if so, how did you get her to, if not, how did you get her to it?
This is something I hear all the time is like, you know, in a lot of times
people have their spouse that doesn't believe in them because they have a
previous mess up where maybe they decided they're going to do something
and they completely flop, but how, how was your wife's support and how did
you get her on board with you?
Cause I'm of course now she's proud of you.
She's like, yeah, my husband's the man because like she, he's going to take
care of us, we have a great lifestyle and all this stuff, this brand new house.
But when you started, was that the case?
That is a great question.
Um, I think it's just like any relationship where trust builds over time.
And so ever since we got married, before we were married, my wife
saw my consistent effort.
We were dating when I was doing sales, selling direct TV, and she saw me put
in the work, put in the work, put in the work, and then it was a long time.
And there was this big investment, right?
To invest in a course.
I'd never bought a course before.
I never bought a group before.
It was a lot of money when you're making only 4,600 bucks a month, right?
I'm like, dude, I'm going to invest in this.
I better, I better make this work.
And my wife was like, you're about to drop thousands of dollars on this.
Are you serious?
And I was like, yes, I absolutely am going to, and it's going to be the best
decision we ever made.
I was so set because my mindset was, it wasn't, oh, I'm going to buy this
thing because I have some savings and give it a go.
It was like, I am going to do this.
I am committed and I will gain my freedom.
This will happen.
And so when I explained it in that way, I was like, babe, look,
people are doing this.
Other people have made this possible and I can hustle in that way.
I can hustle in that same way.
They're not any smarter than me.
Um, I can figure this out and I'm going to grind.
If it takes, I was committed for multiple years.
I was like, if I have to grind and I don't make money doing this for one
year or two years, that's okay.
I'm committed for the long haul because I have this vision of in five years, I'm
going to own a business like these other people, but I could see their timelines
and I could see people who were doing this in a year, two years.
And I was, okay, I'm going to commit for two years and see where I'm at.
I'm just going to grind, push every day, push every day.
And so when she saw that commitment, she was like, okay, we've never spent
this many thousands of dollars on anything, but like you have my trust
and you're going to do this.
It's going to be great.
So she gave me the green light and I'm like, so grateful that she did, you know,
she's a nurse.
And so she basically had all of our savings and was investing it in me,
which was an honor, but also like a responsibility.
So, um, that mindset going in to just be like, I'm going to make this work.
Um, I think it's kind of what you want to have.
Um, and that's how, like, if you're not, I guess on the other side, if you're,
if you're thinking right now, like, Oh, I'm not consistent.
I've said things and I don't do them.
Like that's okay.
The past is irrelevant.
All that we care about is now and each day moving forward.
So build the self-confidence in yourself day by day with those little decisions.
What are you going to commit to today?
Are you going to commit to waking up at a certain time?
Like start doing that thing.
Are you going to commit to go work out for 15 minutes, 30 minutes, 45 minutes a
day, what level are you willing to commit to?
And if you do it every single day, you'll build that trust in yourself.
But the people around you, your wife, your spouse, they'll start seeing that
and they'll trust you more.
And they'll be like, he keeps his word.
He keeps his word to himself.
He keeps his word to his family.
I trust him with this big investment because he is consistent in all these
other areas, of course, he's going to be consistent in this too.
So I think it's just like a muscle.
If you feel like, Oh, I'm not consistent.
I don't trust myself.
Like you got to build that.
Start where you're at and just like little by little, boom, keep stacking
wins, keep stacking wins.
And once you're consistent with one thing, add another until now you're unstoppable
and you're just able to achieve everything that you want to super quickly.
So that's kind of my thought on that is build the trust.
If you don't have it work today on just building that little trust, you'll
strengthen your relationship with your spouse, you'll strengthen your
confidence in yourself and you'll get your results step by step, brick by
brick building over time.
Oh yeah.
I mean, dude, I had the same thing.
Like I was doing door to door and I proved myself, you know, and my wife was
like, yeah, okay, this guy knows what he's doing.
Like, and so then when I made my next decision, which was to start a software
company, I didn't even have to ask her.
But then of course that failed and it kind of lost her trust.
So then I was back on like, you have to continually make sure that people
around you know that you're going to take care of them.
It's like this big thing, especially I feel like with, uh, with, uh, oh shoot.
Can you still hear me?
Oh, there we go.
You're still good.
Okay.
My internet shake anyway.
Um, but then guys, the point being is that if you guys are having an issue
with your spouse or with your significant other, like having that belief in you,
it's probably because you don't, you've never given them a reason to trust you.
And so for me, when I got into this business, ultimately, like I had made a
mistake or two.
I had lost money in the stock market.
I w you know, I lost like $50,000 on a stock.
I didn't really properly check out.
And so I had to just make the, like, I, I tried to get her blessing and she's
like, basically it was like, no.
And I had to make, I had to, I had to just make the, uh, the presidential
decision that even though it was a no, I had to, I still had to do it.
So I went ahead without her permission with the mentality, like I have to make
this work or I'm going to be toast for my entire relationship.
So, um, and that's exactly what I did.
And we had a little day or two where she was upset, but I was like, look, I'm
the one that's in charge of making money for this house.
I'm going to make this work.
And what, to your point, when you change your mentality from like, you know, I'm
going to give it a couple months or whatever, and you're like, I am going to
make this work because Zach Powell made it work, I can make it work, which
means it's possible and I will do it 10 years.
If it takes it, I'm not thinking about anything else.
I'm just going to focus.
You can make anything work.
You can go make money in an MLM.
You can make money selling fricking lotions and potions or door to door.
It's just that you have to change the mentality.
Like I'm going to do it until it works and remove all the distractions.
Um, and you can make it work.
So any of you guys that are hesitant about starting an SEO business, starting
a Legion agency, doing digital real estate, you, you can make money in anything.
You just have to do it long enough and you have to just say, I'm going to do it
until and the, and it will work.
It will work.
It's that simple.
So anyway, Zach Powell, I know it's like nine 15 to where you're at.
It's eight to eight 13 in the morning, dude.
Day's just getting started for me.
So thank you for hopping on again, guys.
Um, I'm going to drop this link one more time, zachpowell.co and I'll try to drop
the rest of your links inside of the, the description.
Thanks for being on, bro.
Thanks.
We'll talk soon.
And see you.